♪ ♪
>> Tucker: SOME OF
SILICON VALLEY'S BIGGEST
INVESTORS ARE BEING ASKED TOUGH
QUESTIONS ABOUT THE WORLD THEY
HELPED CREATE.
SYSTEM SENT A LETTER TO APPLE
URGING THE COMPANY TO DO MORE TO
FIGHT SMARTPHONE ADDICTION AMONG
YOUNG PEOPLE.
GREAT THING FINANCIALLY, BUT NOW
HE SAYS HE REGRETS SOME OF WHAT
THOSE COMPANIES HAVE BECOME.
ROGER JOINS US TONIGHT, THANKS
FOR COMING ON.
>> MY PLEASURE, TUCKER.
>> Tucker: IT'S KIND OF
AMAZING TO EVEN BEGIN THIS
CONVERSATION WITH YOU
CONSIDERING YOU SO FAMOUSLY MADE
GREAT BETS ON BOTH THOSE
THEY ARE DOING.
EXPLAIN YOUR CONCERN.
>> IT'S REALLY SIMPLE.
MYSELF AMONG THE NUMBER, AND
VIEW TECHNOLOGY IS ONE OF THOSE
TRUE.
NOW BECAUSE SMARTPHONES ARE
AVAILABLE 18 HOURS A DAY AND
BECAUSE COMPANIES LIKE FACEBOOK
AND GOOGLE HAVE PERSONALIZED
2 BILLION INDIVIDUAL CHANNELS SO
EACH OF US HAS THEIR OWN
PROGRAMMING ALL THE TIME,
ADDICTION IS ACTUALLY AN
INEVITABLE RESULT OF THEIR
ADVERTISING BUSINESS MODELS.
AND I'M KICKING MYSELF FOR NOT
HAVING SEEN IT.
AT THE SAME TIME, I COMMITTED
MYSELF FULL-TIME WITH MY
PARTNERS TO TRY TO START A
IS THE APPROPRIATE ROLE OF
TECHNOLOGY?
AND I'M DELIGHTED TO SEE THAT
THERE ARE LARGE INSTITUTIONAL
INVESTORS WHO ARE THEIR MARKET
POWER TO TRY TO CALL ATTENTION
BOTH TO THE ISSUE AND TO PROVOKE
COMPANIES TO DO THE RIGHT THING.
>> Tucker: I ASSUME YOU STILL
LIVE OUT IN THE PENINSULA WITH
THIS IS THE MOST COUNTERCULTURAL
THING YOU COULD DO I WOULD
THINK.
>> IT'S A REALLY INTERESTING
THING BECAUSE I THINK YOU ARE
RIGHT.
FOR THE LONGEST TIME,
SILICON VALLEY DIDN'T WANT TO
BELIEVE THERE WAS A PROBLEM.
EVERYBODY LIKES DISRUPTION
BECAUSE IT'S EASY.
WHAT THEY DON'T WANT IS TO BEAR
THE CONSEQUENCES OF HAVING DONE
WROTE THIS LAST WEEKEND THAT
BROUGHT CEOs TO ME TO START
CONVERSATIONS FOR THE FIRST
TIME.
THAT'S NOT WHAT THIS IS ABOUT.
COUNTRY, I'M WORRIED ABOUT
DEMOCRACY.
I'M WORRIED ABOUT WHAT GOES ON
IN THE WORLD.
I JUST THINK THAT WE DON'T WANT
SAD, WE DON'T WANT TO BE MADE
MORE UNSUCCESSFUL.
AND WISH FOR SURE DON'T WANT
THAT TO HAPPEN TO OUR KIDS.
>> Tucker: WHAT YOU THINK THE
RIGHT WAY -- YOU ARE SAYING THIS
IS A VERY INFORMED, UNUSUALLY
INFORMED PERSON ON THIS QUESTIO,
INFORMED PERSON ON THIS QUESTIOH
INFORMED PERSON ON THIS QUESTIOI
INFORMED PERSON ON THIS QUESTIOB
INFORMED PERSON ON THIS QUESTIOS
INFORMED PERSON ON THIS QUESTIOT
UNDERSTAND IS THAT THERE ARE A
LOT OF BAD THINGS THAT CAN
YOUTUBE KIDS.
WE THINK ABOUT PRODUCT LIKE
SNAPCHAT.
THESE ARE PRODUCTS, THE BUSINESS
MODEL IS DESIGNED ABOUT THE
PARENTS NEED TO RESTRICT USAGE
OF THIS PRODUCTS.
ONE OF THE SAD THINGS, ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT MAKES ME ANGRY
KIDS USAGE OF THE PRODUCT THAT
THEY ARE ENCOURAGING EVERYONE
ELSE TO USE.
I THINK THE FIRST THING TO DO IS
YOU HAVE TO EXPLAIN TO THE KIDS,
THERE'S A LOT OF BAD STUFF GOING
ON HERE AND IT'S NOT YOUR FAULT.
I WISH WE HAD CAUGHT THIS BEFORE
IT HAD BECOME AN EPIDEMIC
PROBLEM.
>> Tucker: EVERYTHING YOU HAVE
SAID MAKES SENSE, IT SEEMS
OBVIOUS.
FOR OUR VIEWERS WHO DON'T KNOW
WHAT YOU ARE, I WOULD ENCOURAGE
THIS IS PROFOUND.
YOU REALLY ARE RIGHT IN THE
MIDDLE.
>> THIS WAS A HUGE CHANGE FOR
>> Tucker: IT'S AMAZING YOU
ARE DOING IT AND I'M GRATEFUL